bonjour à vous jean marc alors pour être
très concret est ce qu'on doit
s'attendre à des annonces de la part du
président de la république concernant le
port du masque obligatoire
oui donc tous des espaces publics à
l'intérieur d'ailleurs à l'extérieur
c'est évidemment probable parce qu'il
existe évidemment un risque de reprise
de cette épidémie les chiffres ne sont
pas ne sont pas très bon et puis il
existe aussi depuis deux ou trois
semaines on le voit un espèce de
relâchement dans la pratique des gestes
barrières une pression très forte des
médecins des personnels sur prégnant et
puis aussi des chefs d'entreprise pour
renforcer les mesures de lutte contre le
virus alors ces mesures de lutte contre
le virus sont très connus il s'agit
d'abord de porter un masque pour se
protéger et protéger les autres
il s'agit aussi d'accroître les
dépistage par test et en traçabilité des
chaînes de de contagion tout ça existe
mais on peut pas dire que ce soit
respectée alors vous avez un relâchement
le dizet qui est assez coupable dans les
comportements notamment le port du
masque qui est quand même le seul moyen
de se prémunir contre la contamination
dont une reprise d'ailleurs de la
circulation du virus il y a eu des
recommandations bien sûr de porter le
masque notamment dans les transports
publics ou c'était quasiment obligatoire
dans le train dans le métro et ça a été
suivie essai suivi d'entre elles métro
mais ça devrait l'être également dans
les commerces et là dans les commerces
où on s'aperçoit bien il suffit d'aller
dans un hypermarché dans un magasin de
le port du masque n'est pas n'est pas un
n'est pas née café n'est parfait donc il
ya un toit véritablement un problème de
ce côté là et il le président à vie ne
peut que imposer le port obligatoire
avec sanctions financières à la clé bien
sûr n'a pas fait l'objet de polémiques 1
depuis on l'a vu durant la crise
sanitaire on se demande pourquoi le
gouvernement n'a pas attendu le masque
obligatoire dès le départ on écoute et
ça c'était ça c'est le problème de la
france au début du démarrage de la crise
c'est vrai que la sphère du masque a été
politisée très rapidement je crois que
la première raison qui met dans
l'embarras le gouvernement sait qu'il
comptait un peu sur la responsabilité
individuelle
ça n'a pas marché c'est d'ailleurs assez
curieux
parce que en avril et en mars on était
souvenez-vous quasiment au bord de la
guerre civile parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
de masque et c'est vrai qu'il y avait
pas de masque mais aujourd'hui qu'on en
a bien les français qui les réclamait ne
les portent plus alors je crois qu'il ya
aussi une deuxième raison c'est que au
début le président et les autorités
médicales d'ailleurs qu'il le peut le
supporter ont expliqué que le masque
était pratiquement inutile
en réalité il n'y en avait pas c'était
la raison pour laquelle il disait que ce
n'était pas donc ils ont un peu menti
alors aujourd'hui ça leur est quand même
très difficile de venir dire la vérité à
savoir qu'ils se sont trompés que les
masques soufre indispensable président
de la république est coincé un peu là
dessus et je crois qu'il va devoir
assumer le passé pour prendre cette
décision et en faire la pédagogie c'est
ce qui va sans doute se passer pendant
son allocution du 14 juillet alors c'est
vrai qu'on sent tous contents ça c'est
nécessaire d'apporter ce masque pourquoi
lier pas écouté il est parce que le
virus n'a pas disparu et tant qu'on
n'aura pas de traitement au pas de
vaccin il faudra on sera bien obligé de
se protéger puis de se tester pour deux
pour bourrer des pistes et ceux qui sont
contaminants ou pas c'est le seul moyen
sont les seuls moyens sinon nous serons
obligés de revenir au confinement et ça
c'est pas possible sinon on tue
d'économie vous voyez bien ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays il ya la
plupart des pays européens sont en train
de revenir à déconfinement partiel parce
qu'il ya des relâchements les
entreprises et tous les employeurs aussi
aujourd'hui en france demandent le
masque pour pouvoir continuer de
travailler alors c'est peut-être
liberticide 1 mais je crois que la santé
publique est en jeu donc il faut
accepter comme on accepte où on a
accepté autrefois d'arrêter de fumer en
public ça a été effectivement un drame
politique à l'époque et une vingtaine
d'années où on a accepté aussi l'apport
de la ceinture de sécurité en voiture
là encore c'était un débat politique
incroyable mais c'était pas évident mais
c'est passé dans les moeurs dans des
pays asiatiques le port du masque ne
pose pas de problème dans les pays
occidentaux c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais tous les pays européens s'y met
progressivement donc on va rendre le
masque obligatoire avec je vous disais
des sanctions financières à la clé donc
votre pronostic
ils finesse le masque à sera obligatoire
à peu près partout à peu près partout
absolument si on ne veut pas être obligé
de se confiner si on devait pas être
obligé de se ré enfermé
comme on l'a fait pendant deux mois il
va falloir accepter le masque dans les
transports c'est pratiquement déjà fait
dans les magasins il va falloir
l'imposer dans la rue dans les salles de
spectacles de concerts dans les salles
de cinéma n'ont alors ça va pas être
forcément très commode très pratique
mais c'est bien bien bien bien une
pratique on va être obligé de t'accepter
à l'école et à l'université vous savez
que la décision a déjà été prise pour le
mois de septembre
c'est le premier moyen de restaurer la
confiance dans ce pays il faut parler
relance il faut parler distribution
d'argent subvention est bien sûr mais
pour que ça marche pas il faut
absolument éliminer les facteurs de
risques sanitaires tant qu'on aura
c'était paix de damoclès sur la tête et
bien la machine économique la vie
sociale ne pourra pas représenter
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre à
chacun que êtes économiste martial